welcome
my name is alan gerber i'm the director
of the institution for social and policy
studies
and today's event is an isps democracy
event
isps has been holding a series of events
this year
bringing together experts from yale and
beyond to shed light on key questions
concerning american politics
governance and democracy this is the
last event in the isps democracy series
this academic year
and will continue with new events this
coming fall
before we begin today's event i'd like
to thank the organizers
uh who put everything together and and
without whose help we wouldn't be able
to hold these events
that would be pam greene pam lamonica
torrey bilsky and the more peer a little
bit about today's logistics
after introductions of the panelists uh
each panelist will talk for about 10
minutes
followed by discussion and a question
and answer period
modern by moderated by stephen wilkinson
please save your questions till the end
during the question and answer period
you will be able to use the raise hand
button on the bottom of the zoom screen
you can also send questions to the
panelists
via chat please keep your questions
brief
this event is being recorded and if you
need technical assistance
please email isps
yale.edu so now i'd like to introduce
all of tonight's panelists at once they
will talk
one after another without interruption
here are tonight's panelists or this
afternoon's panelists uh
first elisa selles lisa is
assistant professor of statistics and
data science at yale
uh she is a co-founder of the
computation and society initiative at
yale
she's an expert on artificial
intelligence and ethics
and her research focuses on how
algorithms
encode and perpetuate social and
economic biases
her work has included designing voting
techniques that allow for the election
of diverse committees including the
implementation
of the of including the implementations
fair elections in switzerland project
which is what i believe she'll be
talking about or focusing her remarks on
this afternoon our second speaker is
mark gordon
mark is the founder and chairman of
tower research capital llc
one of the leading computerized trading
firms in the world
gordon advocates for livable streets
alternative transportation and open
government
as the founder and chairman of open
plans a non-profit devoted to the
pursuit of smart planning
and civic engagement through media and
digital tools
he is the chairman of reinvent albany a
non-profit focused on transparency
accountability and good government in
new york state
he is a graduate of yale university with
a bs in electrical engineering
and an ms in electrical engineering from
stanford as well as an mba from the
harvard business school
our third panelist is helen landmore
landmark is associate professor of
political science at yale
her new book open democracy reinventing
popular rule for the 21st century
came out this fall and princeton
university press
the book discusses democratic
representation
and how we could open up our electoral
institutions to ordinary citizens
including via what she terms open
mini publix landomur's previous book
democratic reason
was awarded the 2015 david and elaine
spitz prize
for best book in liberal and or
democratic theory and
the ideas knowledge and politics best
book award
by the american political science
association
alain is a policy expert engaged in
several initiatives to promote democracy
working with governments and think tanks
around the world
and our fourth speaker is rob richie
richie is president and ceo of fair vote
rob founded fair vote in 1992
uh fair vote is a non-profit
organization that researches and
advocates election reforms
to increase voter turnout accountable
governance and fair representation
he has been involved in introducing
rank-to-choice voting
in states and more than 20 cities he's a
graduate of haverford college
where he serves on its corporation
our moderator is stephen wilkinson
stephen is the milwaukee professor of
india and south asian studies and a
professor of political science
and international affairs he is the
currently the henry r luce director of
the macmillan center
for international and area studies
wilkinson is a member of the american
academy of arts and sciences
and his research focuses on south asia
his most recent book
army and nation examined india's success
in managing the colonial army
it inherited in 1947 he has previously
published votes and violence
electoral competition and ethnic riots
in india
which examines the roots of communal
violence in south asia
that book was the winner of the woodrow
wilson prize of the american political
science association
for best book on government politics and
international affairs
so with that let me turn it over to our
panelists and our moderator
our first speaker is professor selas
hello everyone thank you so much for
that introduction alan it's really great
to be here as part of this
series and with all these amazing
panelists i'm really excited about the
conversation that we'll be having today
um so what i wanted to talk about today
is
representation in multi-window voting
and in particular a case study of
some workers really lucky to be a part
of
which happened in switzerland in 20
2017 2018. so what uh
was going on there is in switzerland
there's different cantons so you can
think of a canton kind of like a state
and the canton of vod had
decided by a vote to rewrite its
constitutions it was completely starting
from scratch
and of course the next question once you
decide to rewrite the
constitution is who is actually going to
be doing that rewriting
and there was a lot of concern and a lot
of debate in the public sphere as to
how one could ensure that in this
rewriting process
the interests of every citizen
in the canton of ward would be
adequately represented
when rewriting these rules so
um so while there
i was working at bell at the time in the
neighboring canton
i was lucky to get connected with a
group of
activists and also various political
parties who are very interested
in the concept of finding representative
ways um to conduct these elections
that still adhere to some of the usual
principles
that we have when conducting conducting
an election
in terms of maximizing the number of
votes that we would have
so in a traditional what do we call a
traditional multi-winner voting election
if you want to say elect four candidates
maybe you have eight candidates that are
running
and you want to elect four of them
normally one person comes in
they can cast their votes the next
person comes in they cast their votes
and so on and so forth
until everyone has cast their votes in
multi-winner elections often you get to
vote for more than one person so it
might be a little bit different than
some elections oh
sorry then other elections that you
might be familiar with
but everyone casts one by one everyone
casts their votes at the end of the day
you just add them up see how many votes
each particular candidate had
and once you do that you sort those
votes
from highest to lowest and traditionally
the top candidates up to however many
you need for your
committee win so if you're electing four
candidates
here are your four winners of this mock
cartoon election
so the problem sorry i don't know what's
going on with my slides today
so the problem with this is that this
can result in
very disproportionate and groups of
candidates
that are elected with respect to
criteria that you might care of with
respect to representation
such as gender or age or race or
locality
so the question was how can we
have an election that still satisfies
some representation type of constraints
so for example one could have a criteria
that says
we would want equal or roughly equal
numbers of men and women to win
so if you have one criteria such as this
and you can partition your candidates
it's pretty easy to know
what you should do you just take
say the you you can of course satisfy
these constraints trivially
by taking any two women and any two men
in this toy example but that's of course
not what you want to do what you want to
do is take
the two women that have the most votes
and the two men that have the most votes
and that
and that seems reasonable right you're
satisfying this criteria
but you're also adhering to
this prioritization of the votes right
you're still speaking to
what the people are voting for right so
the goal overall in these types of
questions is select a committee with the
most votes
that still satisfies the kind of
diversity constraints that you would
care about the problem is that if you
have
more than one criteria these
this becomes computationally hard and
that's the perspective that i approach
it from my background is in computer
science
i'm in the statistics and data science
department here at yale and
that's that's basically when um when i
was able to step in
and play a role the question is how can
we balance multiple criteria because
we care about representation across many
different
many different dimensions and along with
some colleagues i was able to work on
this problem and come up with some
really interesting technical solutions
in the vein of approximation algorithms
that help you come up
with help you design this in a way
that once you collect all of these votes
you can do exactly what you wanted right
you satisfy all these criteria
and conditioned on satisfying all the
diversity and representation
criteria that you care about
you return a committee you produce a
committee that has the most number of
votes
so it was really exciting to be a part
of this and actually be able to have
this type of solution um implemented
and used in this particular election of
course this is just
one piece right so one piece was the
design of the approximation algorithm
thinking of this computationally looking
at the algorithm design
and it's a very interesting piece but
it's just one part of the equation
i think a very large part of the
equation
which several of my co-panelists here
would be able to speak more to is how
what are the good ways to design this
process as a whole
right so who is even deciding what are
the right constraints
what are the right categories how do we
even decide what is the representative
sample and what we what
um the process that was used in this
particular
case study that i'm and then i'm talking
about what we did was a two-stage
process so
first um well two
process leading up to that uh in terms
of
um different community events a lot of
discussion that happened
in the public realm but basically
when it came down to vote first um a set
of constraints were proposed so
should the committee be representative
across gender should it be
representative across race should it be
represented across religion
etc so different places where one could
um enforce representation so first one
voted on the criteria
and what that would look like and then
um
about a month later was the actual
election that ran just to vote on the
candidates themselves so that's that's
how this particular
election worked although there would of
course be many potentially different
ways
to design this process and to elicit
those initial votes
in this particular in this particular
case
there were there was of course a canton
as a whole but there were different
different um like regions which within
each canton that were each
having an election so it was really kind
of eight elections that ran in parallel
and the biggest one was a committee of
size 18 that was being elected from
50 candidates and each voter could vote
for 18 candidates and the type of
criteria that were elicited via this
process
that they agreed upon was one for gender
one for age and one for locality so
there's a lot of
political tension between people living
in cities
and people living in the countryside so
that was one of the
one of the places in which and diverse
representation
was required in this in this election
and then once that was satisfied we
could use our our type of
technical fair multi-winner voting
solution so i just wanted to present
this case study i think there's
again many different people on the
panelists that can speak to different
parts of this process as a whole
and i look forward to hearing your
questions and i'm happy to dive into any
more of the details on on the different
aspects of this
um on the technical side i worked with
lin zhang
ninja huang vijay kaswani in the sheets
vishnu
and then our partners in particular was
a non-profit called the pal situa
with florian evanka and johan rochelle
so i just wanted to
say my thank you to them as well it was
really a fun and exciting project to be
a part of
and um i'm happy to share it with you
thank you
hi i'm mark corton um i'd like to first
thank
alan for inviting me to participate and
everyone who's put this together it's
really an honor for me
to be included in this group and be
asked to talk
i'm gonna speak about the problems with
mass elections
and present what i call the micro
democracy working group
alternative um
so um i have been
quite involved in
politics or you know civic engagement in
new york city and new york state for
quite a while
and i have seen the structural problems
that that exist and it seems like good
government groups are always
fighting a system where
um the entrenched interests
are are working for themselves and
and not in what you would think of the
interests of the
the general public and after
you know fighting time and again and
through election cycle again
it just seemed like the the structure of
the system
was was so fundamentally flawed that i
began
to think that the problem comes down to
um the the very nature of mass elections
and i'm sure a lot of people are are
very aware with you know lots of
problems that we have with
poor quality leaders and corruption in
the in the system
um and and i've just seen
you know time again the the corrupting
nature of elections
as candidates are required to make
promises
get money um build coalitions and so
frequently what you have is sort of good
people who are forced to corrupt
themselves
just to get elected and that creates
um all sorts of of issues and
and you know all sorts of corruptions
and problems we have in our
in our government and i'm sure i don't
have to tell um people here about
about lots of these um so i started
thinking about
how it would be possible to corrupt to
correct
to build an alternative system that um
both has um is representative and
captures democratic attempt
but also is is resistant to corruption
and attracts and selects good leaders
and after thinking about it i have
formulated some ideas
which i will um share here so it's
basically
based on a working group
system so rather than having
um mass elections where everybody in the
population
is expected to participate um in a very
very
thin and trivial way in lots and lots of
elections
and most uh you know as most people know
in most elections your vote really
somehow
doesn't matter very much the the concept
of democratic participation
would be shifted towards one that is
much
chunkier of occasionally participating
in a working group
that would um
be taking a very specific decision so
rather than
you know having a small say in lots of
lots of decisions
really this focused attention is
partially designed to to get a better
outcome so i i imagine a
three-step process so the first um
step is an is an election and it's it's
actually a it's but it's a
micro-election a very very
small election among a group of perhaps
somewhere between
40 and 100 neighbors so this election
is meant to be you know not very
daunting
um easy to campaign for um
among people that are hopefully well
known to the um
to the to the candidates and the reason
that i i have had thought that having
these microelections would be good is
because the fact is that
most people are
are not very engaged in in politics and
civic events
and rather than um you know some people
are just too busy
don't have time so rather than trying to
get people who are not particularly
engaged to be engaged
that would have a chance to to get
people who could be representative
of their own community and who would
care to be
engaged and and still having these very
small elections would be
give you a fairly good representative
sample of the
of the population so basically at the
end of this
process of micro microelections about
one percent of the population
would be chosen as micro representatives
or
people that would be available to serve
on working groups later
so then the the next step would be
staffing working groups and
this would be done randomly so really
these working groups
would work much more similarly to
um to wait juries function right now
where people were chosen at random
to participate in a jury this people
who are would be chosen from random of
the pool of micro representatives
to participate in these working groups
and then
the the process that i imagine
for for choosing uh office holders
would be decomposed and the
the example that i'm presenting here
um is is something that i think of as an
election
for um a reasonable sized office so
maybe a member of the house of
representatives or
governor of a moderate-sized state or a
mayor of
a city this process could be scaled i
mean obviously a process that involves
a hundred people is too much to choose
members of a local school board
and maybe too few to choose the the
president of the united states
but still the these process can be can
be scaled
um for for the appropriate size but
the important thing or the the the steps
that i have decomposed it to
here so the three steps are
um choosing the the candidates to be
considered
doing research on those candidates and
then finally
choosing the the final office holder and
a big part of the reason that i am
suggesting breaking it up into different
uh different job functions is
to reduce the risk of corruption um
i think it's quite possible again
particularly for large and high-stakes
elections
that having um a small number of people
i mean maybe as few as
um a hundred who are you know having a
you know a very strong say
in the process of choosing the
the the final office holder those people
are obviously
could be easily targets of bribes and
threats and things like that
again if you're talking about choosing
the mayor of a small town maybe these
are not really issues
for much bigger offices much more so for
if you're talking about choosing the
president you might want to
choose the people and quickly sequester
them away so they couldn't be corrupted
um but really what this
you know a big part of why i think
this could be a a superior solution
is that you you have people who have the
time
and you know a reason to focus a reason
to invest time and effort
in in really becoming educated about
the the the people who are involved
putting in time to be
thoughtful one of the great challenges
with mass elections
is that you have so many people who have
so little stake in the system
that it's it's very hard for them to to
merit
investing the time to be making an
informed decision
so by having these much more engaged
informed deliberative bodies
the hope is that the um
the um the the choice that will be made
will be much more rational
and and and you have people who are much
more engaged
and a lot of the techniques that we see
now in terms of
mass disinformation in these social
media campaigns and
all the different things that that are
distorting
the democratic process now this process
that i'm proposing
is somewhat immune or at least resistant
to that now there are other
corrupting um you know vectors that
could be used to
to attack this but i i do think that the
fact that you
bring random people together
for a brief period of time and then um
then disband these committees when it
does when they're done
means that the the
the target for any sort of corrupting
attack is really
ephemeral and it can it can be that
hopefully would would make this whole
system
very resistant to corruption which or at
least fairly resistant
which i think is really one of the the
main things that i've been um
shooting for in my design of this system
um
so um thank you very much for taking the
the time to listen to me i as opposed to
everyone else involved here
this is i'm an amateur i'm not involved
in academia
but i really am interested in working on
these ideas so if anyone is interested
in um engaging i'd be really happy to
talk to people
here is my information um
and and i i hope to to be able to make
some connections so thank you very much
hi everyone uh i guess it's my turn i'm
ellen landmark
i am i'm not going to use a powerpoint
because i suspect that i am the reason i
don't need a powerpoint is that my idea
is much simpler than what's been
presented so far
uh instead of offering what i see as
complicated ep cycles to salvage the
current system i propose changing the
system altogether
the main problem i see with what we call
political representation today as i
diagnosed in my book open democracy is
that this
type of representation and the rating
formic corresponds to is fundamentally
exclusionary
uh electoral representation as
aristotle montesquieu bernard more
recently have told us over and over
again
is an aristocratic selection mechanism
based on an egalitarian and
inegalitarian principle of distinction
why because elections only empower those
who stand out socially in the eyes of
most
this is why the greeks of classical
athens did not use
elections to staff political offices
instead
they used a lottery based system that
distributed power
equally among the individuals who
qualified as citizens
citizenship was defined in exclusionary
ways it's true in the mentioned grace
but distribution of political office
among citizens was perfectly inclusive
and egalitarian
we moderns by contrast reinvented
democracy in a very elitist form
choosing elections as the primary
mechanism making them to select
representatives
meaning to select people who are going
to stand for
us and make decisions on our behalf on
our behalf
and even as the franchise has kept
expanding since the 18th century and the
restrictions on who can run for office
have disappeared
access to power in electoral democracies
remains
limited to those who can win elections
again because they have attributes that
are not widely distributed in the
population
say charisma height intelligence
but also money and connections meanwhile
other people's power perhaps 95
98 of the of the rest of the people
is limited to voting for such people
every four years
so why is that a problem you might ask
well not only does it mean that we do
not live in authentic democracies
since for most of us representative
democracy means being ruled and
almost never ruling but electoral
democracies tend to suffer from the
blind spots one would typically expect
from oligarchy creations
they have a tendency to ignore among
others they're poor
they're young they're minorities of
color and the losers of economic
policies like free trade or austerity
measures
this is so because these people rarely
make it to
positions of elected power or any power
at all for that matter
yet if these people are not in the room
where laws and policies get deliberated
on and made
not only do their interests fail to be
taken into account
but even if they are taken into account
such interests are not as likely to be
served properly
for lack of a proper first-hand
perspective applied to explaining and
promoting them
in the u.s these blind spots of
electoral regimes
have harmed the welfare of the african
american community since the birth
of american democracy and more recently
the welfare of the working class since
the rise of neoliberalism in the 1980s
in france similarly a government
consisting of largely urban
educated individuals who live in city
centers and
bike to work were shocked to discover
that the well-intentioned fuel tax
in november 2018 could generate the
sometimes violent pushback of peri-urban
lower middle-class people
causing the rebellion now known as the
yellow west
this elitist bias of electoral democracy
cannot be fixed
it is intrinsic to elections and may get
worse with time or under conditions of
growing economic inequalities
can be mitigated but it cannot be fixed
my solution consists in finally facing
up to this reality to this fact
and considering alternative modes of
representation that are
more inclusive and egalitarian namely
more democratic
in the proper sense of the term the
innovation here is both conceptual and
institutional
i propose to decouple the idea of
democratic representation
and the idea of electoral representation
these are not
synonymous or in other words are
proposed to render elections
optional to the concept of democratic
representation
second i develop a vision of democracy
that i call open democracy
partly based on this new non-electoral
concept of representation
and i argue that only in such a regime
would we be truly politically equals and
able to avail ourselves of the entire
collective intelligence of society
an open democracy is structured by five
institutional principles
participatory rights deliberation the
majoritarian
principle democratic representation and
transparency
but here is not the place to develop the
full vision for open democracy so
let me simply focus on this idea of
democratic representation
as distinct from electoral
representation and on the core
institution of an open democracy
that this democratic representation
translates into namely the open mini
public
a central contender for a type of
political representation that is
inclusive and accessible to all
equally is indeed what i call
lotsocratic representation
that's representation based on random
selection or selection by lot
examples of lot aquatic bodies are the
council of 500
of classical athens as well as its large
popular juries
and under modern circumstances things
like cities and juries consensus
conferences deliberative schools
citizens assemblies and the like all
qualifiers type of mini publics
because they aim to present a miniature
portrait of the people
although technically this is only true
of very large ones
so what if instead of elected chambers
we used randomly selected ones to set
the agenda for the policy or even make
laws
the advantage of random selection is
twofold first it creates a much more
egalitarian distribution of power
if we institutionalize such bodies at
all levels of the quality and perhaps
also informed hospitals and schools say
and with enough rotation all of us would
have an equal chance and a real chance
of exercising real power
over the course of our life not just
consenting to it
um at regular intervals and if this is
true i think even if we need to
implement
a stratified random sampling rather than
pure sortation
because for smaller bodies this is the
only way to get the
categories we care about represented
somewhat fairly
it is in that sense a democratic
improvement over elected parliaments
where most of us
we never set foot second a random
selection or stratified random sampling
reproduces in small the cognitive
diversity of the larger group
namely the different ways of thinking
present in the population
this minimizes the risk of blind spots
and increases our chances of making good
decisions for the group
i thus propose as the heart of a
considerably reformed democracy
the open mini public a body of a few
hundred people forming a new kind of
representative legislative body this
body is open
i specify because in order to avoid
closure and disconnection with a larger
public
its deliberation must remain accessible
and visible to the rest of the public
including interest groups who can input
those deliberations at
any stage for example via the use of
online crowdsourcing platforms
this allows the smaller body to tap the
information of the larger public
but also promotes a larger public debate
about the nature and content of the
deliberation going on
which is important for the legitimacy of
the mini public to begin with
so it's highly unlikely at this stage
that a legislative open mini public of
this kind
is going to replace elected assemblies
though some have been calling for
something like this
and um i personally think that this is
the more coherent idea
as i mentioned again at this stage
what we can realistically consider is
augmenting electoral
democracy and electoral assemblies with
such lotocratic bodies to make
them more truly to make the whole system
more truly representative
even if no replacement occurs but again
some people have called for example
for replacing the canadian senate with
a lot of aquatic body or the house of
lords with a lot of hearty body or the
caesar in france with a lot of everybody
the change still implies a significant
redistribution of power from elected
chambers to the new open mini public
one could imagine having an openly
public legislature specifically about
environmental issues issues around
climate change
or issues about the future and
we could also envisage giving them veto
the power to veto certain bills coming
from the other chambers when they run
again
against its own mission or one could
imagine ad hoc many publics being
convened on certain issues at the
initiative of either government
parliament or the citizen themselves via
the right known as
citizens initiative in the latter case
the recommendations of the one-off mini
public would have to be made at least
somewhat binding on the other
legislative institutions because we know
from experience that otherwise they
largely get ignored
this proposal even it's in its more
reformist and complementary version may
seem far-fetched to you
but in fact a lot of experimentations
around similar ideas
have been under ways for over
20 years a recent oecd report
titled the deliberative wave thus
documents around
deliberative experiments involving many
publics of that kind around the world
um over the last 20 years and just in
the last decade there's been a surge
as well among the more salient examples
i'll just mention
in 2017 in south korea the citizens
assembly of randomly selected citizens
was which was given the final say over
the decision where not whether or not
to continue the construction of two
nuclear reactors
um a decision that was actually
implemented over the country president's
preferred choice
in 2017 as well mongolia passed a law
requiring that a deliberative poll be
held prior to constitutional amendments
in may 2018 in ireland a popular
referendum validated the recommendations
of a specially convened citizens
assembly
of 99 randomly selected citizens to
decriminalize
abortion and this was followed by a
referendum
in which this proposal was approved most
recently in france the citizens
convention for climate which i've
studied and closely observed made
149 recommendations about how to curb
greenhouse gas emissions
in the spirit of social justice half of
those proposals have now been turned
into regulations
and many of them are currently
influencing
various proposals and various um
bills at the smaller scales
at a smaller scale regions are now
interested in using many publics to set
the agenda of the legislative bodies
as has been the case for a year in the
german speaking region of belgium for
example where they had a council of 24
randomly
citizens a very small jury-like body
that could convene um larger citizens
assemblies and set the agenda for the
local parliament
brussels the city of brussels now is
developing so-called deliberative
committees to help guide public policy
at the global level ngos and academics
are now organizing
what's coming up this fall the first
global climate assembly to accompany the
negotiations around the
conference of the parties 2021 in
glasgow
so i'm looking forward to seeing more of
this being tried out in the united
states as well
i believe this is um the only way to
aim for a more democratic kind of
political representation
thank you very much
thank you it's terrific to be part of
this i'm rob richie
i often feel i'm talking about
change in a way that's bolder than most
people but i feel in this
set of presentations maybe i'm i'm being
moderate by
only being for proportional voting for
u.s house elections and
widespread use of rangers voting i will
say there's something important
to me about the electoral process that
doesn't display some of these other bold
ideas but also means that the
seeking consent of the government
reaching out to people
in a process where there's full debate
is something that i certainly want to
make sure stays part of
of any system that we have i'll go ahead
and share my screen
and get into my powerpoint here
so what i'm going to zero in on um
is those i they those ideas of
what we can do statutorily in the united
states and i want to get at it through
the lens of um
why it is particularly important now
um we are in time of sort of heightened
deep political polarization
um and um to us
it's really grounded in the use of
winner take all
voting so election rules um
uh drive behavior we don't think this is
what we're seeing in congress and in
many of our elections
is because of bad people who
who decide to run but they have certain
incentives that drive
what what happens you can certainly see
in very basic ways that the election
rules drive behavior
and just use a couple examples when
you're having presidential nomination
processes
iowa goes first and lo and behold about
50
of events in the first run up to
uh the year before the nomination
contests uh take place take place in
iowa
um the swing states in the general
election for
president are the ones that are tightly
contested uh others are
are not at about 98 of campaign events
and and ads are earmarked to voters in
those 12 states not because the
candidates don't care about the rest of
the voters but
it doesn't it doesn't affect whether
they win or lose
so winner take all means 51 percent of
vote which of course is a majority wins
100 percent
of representation 49 wins zero
and if it gets a little bit uh more
tilted 55 percent or so
it's essentially a done deal if you're
comfortably ahead or hopelessly behind
you can't win
so there's a good book by lee drutman
called the doom loop and i'll sort of
walk through
how things are playing out but we're in
a cycle that's that's reinforcing itself
and things are getting worse and worse
so first most states and districts have
a partisan tilt that's natural that
the parties aren't aren't sort of evenly
uh placed i mean as political
polarization
increases that winner take all rule
means that partisan majorities decide
more and more outcomes
the general election doesn't really
matter so to win
the election uh most candidates don't
really need to worry about the general
election they only need to worry about
how they get
nominated to be part of the majority
party in that area so they'll need to
cater
to those relatively small percentage of
voters that participate in partisan
primaries there's a recent study it's
about you know 10 percent of voters are
really deciding
the great majority of outcomes
um and for some reason okay there we go
and then um as a result congress is now
more prone to gridlock and you can see
just how
difficult it is for the parties to take
on anything
substantive and challenging and actually
do things together their their base
doesn't want them to do it
they're fighting they can get things
done when uh one party runs everything
but even that can be challenging but
certainly when they're divided it gets
really challenging these disputes lead
to greater partisan ill will
the partisan voters therefore become
more fearful and angry of
the base and so the cycle continues and
so so things just keep getting worse and
worse
so how can we sort of get out of this um
we first have to start with the fact
that we're in a very difficult place
in a winner take all election system
more than 80 percent of congressional
races are just
fundamentally safe because of that
winner take all dynamic
fairvote does a report we started way
back about 25 years ago called monopoly
politics
but our insight was that we could make
projections in the great majority of
house races
knowing nothing about the current cycle
just based on the
whether the incumbent was a decent
incumbent and
um in which you could measure in kind of
some simple ways
in the the tilt of the districts and and
and we've been doing this for years
um we could project the 2020 house races
and about 85 percent of races
within a week of the 2018 elections and
essentially get all but one or two right
in some cycles we
get every single one right so it means
that whatever campaigning happens in
those districts doesn't matter
if you look at the underlying nature of
districts um
and and and note the pattern here it
isn't just happen in
when when districts are drawn it's
happening between
cycles of district and just that that
the districts are becoming less and less
competitive
and you're seeing voters split their
tickets less
and they are voting more consistently so
back when i
helped start fairvote back in 92 at that
time
in congress about 112 seats um
had members who represented a district
won by the other major parties
presidential candidates so more than a
quarter of seats were held by someone
who was of
a different party than the candidate
that won that that that carried that
district in
in the presidential race we're now down
to that's only 16 people
less than four percent so almost total
alignment the the
u.s senate is the same way um
uh state legislative races have become
more and more
lined up with presidential races just
basically the partisan label drives
behavior
at the same time the country's going
through this big sort
concept the idea that
people are becoming more alike
politically with others where
they live and you can measure that again
again this isn't gerrymandered this is
just sort of counties
and counties have become more and more
aligned with
um one party or the other at the same
time that people are splitting their
tickets and less
um and you look at sort of the the red
blue map if you have our simplistic
system that we have where it says
democrats or republicans
and there's much more coherence and and
sort of solid blocks of color
which also plays out in in
predictability of races
um so let me talk about the two ideas
that that that we focus on
um both of these are statutory both of
these are getting increasing attention
rankers voting is getting a lot of use
so that is the idea of replacing when
you vote for one person
or you vote at all essentially you you
you go for a ballot where you can just
vote for one person a single choice
ballot
all or nothing you either give a vote to
someone or not with a rancher's ballot
and i'll explain what that means but
it's it's something different
and then we replace a winner take all
rule with a proportional system kind of
like what we
heard about was going on in in
switzerland and indeed is used in most
countries in some form
so ranger's ballot here's a a very basic
one
instead of just ticking off one
candidate you get to say hey here's my
candidate who's my first choice but
i actually do have something to say
about other candidates in in this case
the person saying brown's our first
choice castros are second adams or third
this is simple and easy for voters to do
uh it was introduced say in
five states democratic parties used in
presidential primaries last year
first time vote by mail ballots 99.9
of people cast a valid ballot and a
great majority of people ranked more
than one
um so here's what you do when you count
them up
so you add up the first choices only so
you look at that ballot you only count
first choices
someone wins more than half of the vote
you have a first round winner that's it
if not the candidate that is in last
place um
is um dropped out and and you're only
counting that ballots candidates for
their next choice so everyone has only
one vote accounts
but you get a backup if your favorite is
out so in this case it goes down to
three
you still don't have a majority winner
you knock out the last place candidate
and voila
you have someone over half the votes and
that's all there is to it
um so what does this mean politically so
one
is that it creates the space to have
more than two choices and not have this
immediate finger pointing dynamic where
like why is that person running and
you know right now you're having a kind
of a debate on the republican side where
some people love donald trump some
people don't and they're sort of talk
about whether there should be
another party and there's a lot of
saying like well we can't do that
because we'll split the vote
um you know ralph nader running as a
green party or ross
perot as an independent or what have you
that they don't talk about whether that
person has an
idea that's different or political
philosophy that should be represented
it's just the dynamics that you can't
have more than two people in our
politics
if you break that down you begin to
break down
the binary what it means kind of
politically with outcomes
is that candidates and you really see
this particularly well in
city elections we have lots of good data
from from cities and primaries
and it encourages candidates to engage
with more voters
run more positive campaigns not everyone
being lovely to everyone else but
in court it incentivizes reaching out
and the winners typically
get affirmative preferences from 65 70
of the voters which is an indication of
that sort of reaching out and again it's
being used quite a bit the united states
now
we're up to two states using it for
president and congress um
90 plus colleges and universities sort
of do it on their own 20 cities we might
see as many as 10 more cities using it
in
utah this year so then i'll turn to
multi-member districts now we see a lot
of multi-member districts
in local elections in the united states
still see a number of state legislatures
with them
i actually have three house members here
in maryland um
we heard some about them in switzerland
um now there's a lot of ways you can
use multi-member districts but the basic
idea is you take the
you change from having only one person
trying to represent everyone in a
geographic area so congress
or the u.s house not a single u.s house
member represents any of the same people
that anyone else does
and you go to having say in this example
in massachusetts you go to having
bigger districts with more
representatives so it's three three and
three in this case
if you use the ranked choice system
single transferable vote in a classical
uh terminology um it it takes no longer
takes fifty percent to win
takes a little over a quarter of the
vote to win one out of three seats 50
to win two more than 75 percent to sweep
all three
that high percentage of what it takes to
win all three has a really
interesting impact um so
what does it mean for polarization and
representation david brooks wrote a
great column in new york times a couple
years ago
saying someone reformed to save america
this is this fair representation act
um which has been introduced and is
about to be introduced again
um and what it means for polarization is
that
really there's no safe seats anymore
right so there's so all that kind of
blocked out of the country that
stark red and blue in fact pretty much
every single district
is going to have both parties having the
power to help elect someone from it
um you can have republicans in new york
city and in other cities democrats in
rural areas
and different kinds of democrats and
different kinds of republicans
third parties and independents have a
challenge to win but they can hold the
major parties accountable in a different
kind of way
and then you have a congress that has
sort of a much more sort of centered
uh political center represented but also
it has sort of vibrant representation of
left and right and of course we're not
linear that way and it's sort of a more
three-dimensional reality that that
that that would allow it to function
differently um so it was hr
4000 in the last congress um sort of
to sum up the representation impacts our
simulations show that if
with with this system in place every
single state that has at least three
seats
you would have every voter uh probably
end up being represented by uh
candidates from from from both major
parties um
and again those independents and third
parties having a fighting chance
women would see a dramatic increase in
representation there's a lot of good
data that just showing
going to multi-member districts would
would change that but the more fluid
nature of
choice and competition would would very
likely lead to
to a significant boost just from the
get-go from the system
and people of color would have a really
dramatically different opportunities to
both participate
and and win one way of showing that is
that you can go from california a whole
line of states all the way to my state
of maryland and
every single one of those states every
person of color
would have a the opportunity to join
with other
like-minded voters to help elect a
candidate of choice which would be quite
dramatic when you think that that's the
south and that's part part of the
regions that have been so racially
polarized
so look forward to chatting about with
people i'm rob richie and um
uh i'll pass it on to my next person
okay thanks very much um so
these these have been great one thing uh
i wanted to remind people to is please
use the raise hand button
on the bottom of the zoom screen to ask
your question or else the chat function
uh i'm going to collect those and then
ask questions
um but to get us started i think
um there's one question i'd like to ask
all the panelists which is
uh how much of how much do you hope that
the
these different electoral systems will
make a difference in terms
of uh overall outcome so if we look
around the world
we see big differences uh certainly
across different electoral systems but
i'm struck by the fact that
even within places that have the same
electoral system
there's just enormous variation in terms
of some of the negative things that
people have said that they want to try
and fix in democracy
but that tells us that electoral rules
can make a difference
but not all the difference and i wanted
to get some sense from the panelists
of how much of a difference they think
uh that changing to these
incredibly interesting systems uh will
make to outcomes they care about
and then secondly whether they think
there's any cost to the particular
uh uh mechanisms that they're talking
about
uh is is there a trade-off and and how
do they see the downside
so we can go in the order in which we um
in in which we uh started
and then while that's happening i'll
look at people's comments in the chat
and we'll get ready to call on people
in the chat and when i do call on you
we're going to ask you to go live
and ask the question uh yourself on
video
and um and and so please be ready for
that
okay elisa first here yes
thanks so much steven and thanks again
to all the panelists and everyone for
being here
i yeah that's an incredibly interesting
question and i think
it's very hard for me to say exactly how
much
change it can affect i do think
it's of course who is
setting the rules and setting the tone
for our country
is incredibly important and so i do
think
that um it changing how we
elect people changing if we elect people
all of these things
um can have incredible impact now
quantifying that in some way i'm not
quite sure
how to do that and while i do think
there is a cost
i think that cost is just in terms of
time
and effort and more participation
which sounds like a cost right there's
more work that has to be done
but that naturally is more work of
involving more people involving everyone
into the whole
process that is affecting their lives
and is affecting our future
so it's a good cost to pay if the cost
is
more people have to participate then
that's exactly what we want to do
thank you mark
um i mean obviously the system is large
and complicated and no one change
is is enough in any way a large part of
what i have been thinking about
has to do with just the incentives of
elected
officials because most people
tend to respond to their incentives and
if something
helps them personally they're inclined
to move in that direction
and you know so i've been personally
focused on
on in you know trying to think about how
to mitigate
bad incentives in the system and create
good incentives
but there's obviously so many pieces
to to um how government is structured
and runs
and i think that we're really at a point
where i mean essentially the the systems
that
that we're running with today in the us
are 100 or 200
or more years old and there have been so
many changes to society
to scale to technology i actually think
there are
you know the the possibility of openness
and transparency
due to new computer technology means
that it's possible for people
to have you know much more insight into
the details of
how government works and to perhaps
micro target things so i think there's
a whole i mean i'm hoping that the next
generation will see a range of new ideas
and a whole range of changes to improve
the efficiency and honesty of the system
because
i mean you know right now government
doesn't you know kind of clunks along
but it is
by no means working well in most places
thanks ellen
uh so i i think uh any of these
proposals are improvement on the status
quo
um i do feel though that it will
create a more visible diversity but
without
much of a or not enough of a cognitive
difference if you will in the sense that
at the end of the day
elections remain as i insisted elitist
so
will you bring you will bring about more
you know people of color and women
sort of like demographic categories we
care about because they're easy to grab
to understand and grapple with and but
there are other categories we
underestimate like certain types of
minds that that correspond to
personalities that don't sell well in
elections but
and so i worry that we're still gonna
end up with very biased
you know groups of people in power and
and i think we are losing out on on the
power of um
of greater diversity that way that that
that would also be a lot more
egalitarian so that that's my worry um
and then i would say that this wraps a
question to to mark i
i worry about the
transparency of this scheme which is
quite complicated do we not lose some
some democratic appeal when we have this
multiple steps and there's some
elections some random selection
don't people lose the the chain of
accountability in those schemes
yeah mark please answer um
i actually think that this can be that
there's
you can still have quite a bit of
accountability because i mean right now
i mean we
we elect all sorts of horrible elected
officials
and i don't think you hardly ever see
anyone who feels particularly
bad because they cast a a vote i mean no
one really
feels any ownership of any decision i
mean so certainly the the process that
i've suggested
i i intended to be you know highly
transparent so people you know
we can see how the deliberations work
what they what the
outcome you know what the output is but
also then people
you know a small number of people would
be
very much responsible for protected lead
you know particular leaders so if that
person
did a bad job you know you could go back
and say
you group of people you chose them it's
sort of your fault
again nothing is perfect everything is
imperfect
but i i do think that the
you know the questioning and again you
know you're doing that with your own
work the
the idea that just how somehow polling
large numbers of people
leads to a good decision i i think that
we see the problems with that
and and so trying to find an alternative
i think any of these solutions
you have to try in reality and then sort
of see what works and iterates i don't
think
you know anything is is perfect in the
in the abstract or in all contexts
thank you rob
well i'll say one thing i guess i i
would um
be loathe at this point to not
ground any system in a one-person
one-vote electoral system
so i'm i am a big believer that that's
important and that's a way of sort of
measuring consent of the government
having this
this conversation i think there's
there's interesting
ways to add in some ideas um
that would add dimensions without but
also let's
start by making that dimension work
because it we have so far to go in the
united states that it's sort of easy to
start there because it is
so problematic and so in some ways
transparently straightforward
how to make it much much better our
slogan of fair vote is a more perfect
union and i think part of that
choice was the belief that it's an
ongoing process we're not going to get
perfection so no it's not like we get
the rank just voting for for all of our
elections and the representation act and
we can just
you know say say we're done but it would
be
starkly and importantly better and um
i i think one area that we can think
about um
also is is sort of embracing the fact
that we have a particularly federalized
system in the united states
about half a million elected offices we
have a lot of local government
more more than i i think any other
country
um and uh or at least most countries and
and and that there's an opportunity in
there to try to see if there's ways that
we could generate more
citizen participation and dialogue um
that in a sense
captures some of what people are talking
about here but the reality is right now
people are actually less interested in
in participating at that level
even though it's closer to home so it's
something that i think that we should
work on
last thing i'll say a big fan of things
like participatory budgeting there
already are a lot of kind of creative
things going on out there and we just
need to keep
keep thinking about um different models
to add on
to the electoral one yeah alone
yeah i just want to reply to the point
that um
you know if we care about one person one
vote we have to stay with elections
i i don't think so we can have one
person when was
used in the context of referenda and and
uh you know
all kinds of mass popular voting what i
object to is not the one-person one-vote
principle which of course is central and
would be a part of an open democracy
but the use of that just to select
people who then exercise power on our
behalf i think we should be
using this one person one vote right um
to
make decisions ourselves based on the
recommendations of a randomly selected
body or
or directly it's not a it's not a real
choice
in one thing i think makes a big
difference in the us is just the closed
primaries in so many
uh different states uh that influence
who gets there even in places with the
same electoral system you see that
having a
huge difference anyway let's let's open
it up uh
now to the audience there is a huge
wealth of knowledge and experience and
uh and uh cases uh
that they know about in terms of the
audience so first we'll go to katie
welts
katie
hi um my name is katie wells
i'm a government teacher in springfield
massachusetts
i have a couple questions but i'm going
to start with one for rob just in case i
only get the one
um i um i think one of the fears
in switching up uh the way that we vote
is that um
safe states whether they're red or blue
by
taking steps to make their elections
more fair could give an advantage to
like what's seen as the other side
by taking the safety out of their
elections
while states that don't adopt the
measures retain those safe seats so
there's two parts to my question
do you think there's a way to avoid this
unintended consequence
and um if the changes if the change was
to be implemented
nationwide do you think there's a way to
do it within the confines of the
constitution
as it exists now um given that states
make their own electoral rules
since it seems unlikely that we would
see an amendment to increase voter
fairness
um given the lack of incentive for
existing congress persons to jeopardize
their positions
by removing the safety of their seats
well that's a good question um and and
i'll say i saw it as part of your chat
question too about rangers voting having
lost them about in massachusetts the
good news was
that's the only time it's lost in the
ballot in the last five years
and it's been on the ballot in fif more
than 15 other jurisdictions um
including cities it's won by an average
of more than two to one in every city
voting on it for
for for a while so it doesn't mean you
can throw it on the ballot everywhere
and win but there's a lot of sort of
i think interest for change and the more
we use it
i think the better it can look for
congress you know
you're you're right about the challenge
of how do you have
you know one state be fair or not you
see it play out when people talk about
redistricting reform and you know like
well if we have you know like kind of a
better
uh registering process a fairer one that
might mean more competition and turnover
of incumbents um in our state and the
other states don't then you know
nationally that's actually not fair even
if it's fair in the state but a lot of
states have moved ahead
anyway on that so that isn't a barrier
to change happening state by state
there is a requirement for house
elections that's statutory that's
important it's a federal statute
most recently passed in 1967 after not
having been in place for a while
which is to require single member
districts so this is a
the early congresses had a lot of
multi-member districts um at large
elections
for congress um and uh when a 1929 law
that was sort of associated with also
capping
house size kind of ridiculously at 435
rather than having an ongoing
conversation about increasing the house
um it opened the door to multi-member
districts and some states were doing
that in the 60s so anyway congress said
well let's have
everyone be quote unquote fair by having
single member districts
that isn't actually super fair um as
we've demonstrated and
and um you know mostly non
non-competitive races
and a lot of gerrymandering going on in
a bunch of states
and so the the theoretical basis of the
fair representation act which is
statutory
doesn't require change in the
constitution is to say well let's
actually have states be truly fair
and all simultaneously put in
multi-member districts with a ranked
choice system and have those benefits
that i talked about
so the politics of that are
big and bold um i think grounded in the
logic that that's a good way to do it
um but there's other approaches that may
end up being the way it goes which is
sort of allowing states again to have
the option to do it and it grows more
sort of state by state but
we're sort of launching the conversation
and we're doing it in a climate
where we really need to do something and
that's i think the impetus for congress
they're kind of stuck in a situation
that a lot of them feel
very challenged by and i think that even
if their own seats are safe
operating in congress to get things done
is not safe or
it's it's sort of hard for them to do
what they actually want to do
a lot of the times and that creates i
think the opportunity to actually get
the
the big changes that are usually really
hard to win
okay kent you got one more because you
have questions for a number of the other
people so pick one
okay oh thank you so much for letting me
ask another one um for a len
um one of the criticisms of um
jury selection in some areas of the
united states including connecticut
has highlighted the potential bias in
selection based on
the data that they're generating their
lots from
could you comment on that and do you
have any suggestions about how that
could be avoided
in your proposal um
so that that's a fair criticism um i'll
tell you what the french did which
sounds like it seems to me like a decent
solution they
um they had to select 150 citizens so
what they did is that they generated a
300 um thousand
randomly generated phone numbers there's
a private company that did that
and then they called the people and
gathered their demographics and
ask questions and then they apply quota
sampling to that and then in the end
they
so the the criteria where um age gender
education level uh settlement meaning
whether they were urban or rural
geographic origin we didn't have race
because it's not a legal category in
france
and um and one thing they failed to take
into account i think which was i think a
mistake um
is uh their opinion about climate change
i think that would have been important
to sample as well
but at the end they got 190 voluntary
citizens
to you know that that you know not
representative i think it's too few
anyway to represent the
you know statistically the people of
france but they're really
um diverse and and tracking the main
categories that we
care about um and that way they had a
you know 150 citizens that each session
that was
closer it seemed to be a decent method
okay uh let's let's call on george
lindser
and i hope that christine comes back in
a moment
uh hi thanks steven um i am
a publisher and editor of the american
leader
and uh my question is related to
stephen's opening question
um and first i just want to say
you know i i think systems are no matter
what the system
it's in a way just destined to be hacked
um
and we've seen that with the current
system that we have
um and i do agree with rob that uh
that making a more perfect union is the
goal
and an ongoing process um
so with that in mind my question is this
um where do you see the role of civics
education
uh and by that i i'm including mandatory
service and a nationally standardized
curriculum
um as a solution to the problems we face
relative to systemic change and
although anyone who has a thought on
that i'd be happy to hear it
okay just put your hand up if if you
have thoughts on this
ellen did you
oh i tend to think that a lot of credit
system
has a built-in civics education which is
not just listening to boring lectures
is actually doing and practicing uh what
we are constantly preached
you know so it's socratic practice of
deliberation
and you can start in in school you could
start
at the university you could start in uh
your company
you know there are all kinds of ways
where we could reform governance so that
people are
randomly drawn into these uh
decision-making bodies and learn about
deliberating with
other people decent people who disagree
with them and that that
forges also just bring into contact
people who would never meet otherwise
you you you you know elected circles
tend to
be very homogeneous um on a number of
dimensions when you when you have a
random sample you bring together
a farmer from you know
i don't know wisconsin and uh and a
designer from new york and
and and uh you know and
a nurse from minnesota i don't know
these are people who've never
really encountered people like like
themselves so i think it's really
important in forging a stealing bond and
bridging and you know bringing the gap
between a trump voter and a biden voter
for example crucially
just add just a quick example of policy
um
it might be other scandinavia
scandinavian countries but definitely
norway
um they sort of take this this
responsibility really seriously
that young people are soon going to be
voters they're going to be participants
and um there's there's a much more
intensive civic education than as usual
in the united states but includes
everyone going to the national capital
for doing what often our elite students
get to do here in the us where they're
sort of a mock congress and they
they get to see what congress is like
and uh but they all get to do that and
they get to see the actual congress and
and you know get to kind of a more
hands-on feel for
for what they soon are going to be and
certainly i think we need to
be investing and looking in those kinds
of strategies
thank you um so i don't know if
christine's
uh mike is back on but i'll i'll ask her
a question
she said i like mark gordon's idea and
would support this implementation for
elections such as president
but it would seem an unlikely scenario
for smaller communities for offices such
as mayor etcetera
due to including a number of groups and
the people within each group to do
capable research
and if representatives are not held
accountable now what would need to be
put in place for greater transparency
and less corruption
in order for a smooth uh transition so
this gets us back to this theme that
we've got of maybe there are other
things you need in addition to the rules
uh and i'm curious how you respond mark
um i mean i certainly agree
that the process that that i outlined on
my side was very
heavy i do think the idea of a working
group
model to um select you know the mayor of
a small town still
works but maybe you're taking
you know you know depending on the size
of the town you know maybe it's one
working group with eight people who get
together
to choose you know someone that's
probably known to them to be the mayor
or something like that i think you
you really can have a smaller scale
process and i really do think that there
is value
to the deliberative process um and so
um this this
you know that um
you know people talk and challenge each
other you will get a
a better a better output there
um i'm sorry what was the second part of
the question now i'm already
um it was
let me see
um oh it's about holding people
accountable
so yes what i proposed is you know just
one piece of this and i have ideas
for a a way to
um you know rethink you know large parts
of our system now where we
tend to put responsibility very heavily
on elected leaders but if you want to
take
you know something for example like the
impeachment process
i mean right now we have an impeachment
process that is you know
highly political and you know
and you know really biased and you know
it
you know i don't think very many people
are all that happy with it
but the idea that you would have some
mechanism that
under a certain threshold whether it's a
you know a certain set of working groups
of people or a certain
um you know say you know there we want
to start an impeachment process and
again
call together working groups where you
draw random people
and it could be a larger deliberative
body i mean there are lots of ways
to do it but again i i think one of the
core
um bases to my idea is that average
people tend to be fairly honest
um and as long as they're not part of
the system and compromised by
political loyalties and things like that
they will
not do a perfect job but just doing it
basically decent
job is is better than what we have in
many ways now
and that also um you know bringing
people together
with a specific deliberative focus
allows people to invest the time and
energy
to reach better conclusions than the
kind of very superficial
way that people form opinions based on
mass media or
or whatever whatever you have now so i
think there are lots of ways to include
working groups various different
deliberative bodies
to you know whether it's choosing you
know what do we want the policy on
immigration to be
we could again put together some sort of
um
statistically um valid
deliberative body to then answer that
question and give the administrators
you know say implement the policy that's
been chosen so i think there are a lot
of different ways
to reconfigure things to both get
democratic intent and to get smarter
decision making okay great thanks uh
next up we calling on matthew myers
uh hi um i'm uh undergraduate in
professor lanimore's
class and um i have a question
for professor seles
so i i think it's really interesting to
compare
sort of your version of multi-winner
elections
to mr richie's version and i was
wondering if
when designing the version in
switzerland you considered
a single transferable vote because it
would sort of
have those like you had quotas but that
would sort of do it
built in and incorporate other elements
like ideology that aren't so easily
categorizable
yeah thank you so much for your question
uh that's um
that's very true so these other
types of systems like single
transferable vote end up with much more
representative
committees i was thinking of in terms of
committees but panels are
groups of groups of people it does it
be a very different mechanism
and i think both approaches have
different strengths and weaknesses
and which one you might want to use in a
given context would matter
i think you absolutely identified the
benefit of a single transferable vote
method in that it's
you don't need these um these specific
or bridges
yeah it's frozen um so i hope that eliza
comes back
in uh in a second um
i might just add a a comment on that
just uh because i'll be intrigued to get
more of the specifics of what happened
in switzerland but there are ways to
combine
single transferable boat with some kind
of guaranteed
outcomes by gender or other categories
and it's an intriguing opportunity that
actually single transferable vote
permits within a proportional system so
anyway i'll be interested in hearing
more about the way that it was done
there in switzerland
yeah eliza you froze briefly so uh so
let's go again yes so sorry about that
my internet cut out and i have no idea
what
what you heard or what you didn't hear
so i'll try to not
yeah hopefully this isn't all repetition
for you um what i was saying is that
it's
um both systems are
approaching the same problem right how
do we get a representative
electoral body um through very different
mechanisms
and what i was saying is that which one
you might want in a particular context
would vary so i don't think one is
strictly better than the other
the difference is kind of the mechanism
that is used and the end result so in a
single transferable
vote um what i was saying is matthew
very clearly identified that
one of the huge benefits is that it kind
of implicitly gets
this diversification and doesn't need
these rigid separate categories
as to how many women or how many people
from such a such category and and i
think that is a huge value because it
does allow you to get all these other
more implicit categories i would say the
the downside is that
um while overall you get more diverse
committees or more representation
it's not guaranteed and if you have
groups of people that
are very underrepresented in the overall
population
but still deserve rightly a voice
it generally is not enough to get enough
votes on those candidates
right or it might not be enough
depending on on the particular context
so by actually setting up these kind of
strict
these strict rules you you lose
something in that brittleness but you
also gain something by
first having a guarantee that you're
actually going to get that desired
representation
and making sure that all parts of your
population are represented
thank you um cheyenne sunder
there's shine there
can you hear me yes okay um
so the behavior of elected
representatives
has long been debated what they actually
choose to do whether they represent
they actually behave in a way that
represents
the constituent interests or the
assessment of
a general will general good for society
or something else an interest of your
own
my question is how
do you think your respective proposals
might affect their behaviors of
elected representatives
okay we'll call them people in the order
in which uh they present
uh if they if they would like to speak
and if they if they don't they don't
have to so elisa um
yes so i think um i think there's an
explicit way in which it changes in that
if you have
a more diverse representative body you
just
by nature have to tackle problems
differently because you can't
conveniently ignore a huge part of the
population you're supposed to be
representing
um but i think the other effect that we
that we saw when doing this in
switzerland was that
it was by far the most diverse set of
candidates
that we had seen um in several years so
i
think part of what implicitly happens
when you set up
alternative systems of governance is
that you people who
might otherwise be disillusioned
otherwise there is
no way i have any change in this
election they participate as well
so that's one way in which um kind of
both explicitly and implicitly
the conversation shifts and you end up
getting people with different interests
perhaps or different motivations to be
there and to be part of the process
and then you would otherwise have
yeah i think it's a a very good question
and this
um the the problem of politicians
being motivated by their own interests
has really been
you know was kind of a very important in
my thinking
as i you know tried to design my system
um i mean because at least right now and
again my experiences are
are very much new york based but i think
that their you know what we see here is
um is common elsewhere but the the
dominant political forces in new york
are unions
real estate interests um the government
contractors
and if you look at how the system works
it's basically to benefit those
interests
because those interests are able to
pay directly or indirectly or through
blocks of votes or things like that
um the various politicians and the
politicians are acting
in their interests and not the interests
of the public and i think you see that
all all over um so
i very much tried to create a system
where you didn't don't have
these outside interests having very much
e you know direct sway over the
the government officials the the flip
side of that
is that there is less accountability and
so that is why
i do think it is important if we were to
adopt my system to have these sort of
parallel systems which i talked about
with sort of separate working groups to
provide
some sort of accountability there um
but at least for me this idea of
of interest of the the politicians is
really core to everything because
at least for me it doesn't necessarily
matter you know
what a particular government official
looks like or which group they represent
if they're really just representing
themselves and whatever interest is
capable of buying them off
and so i i think the id you know this
idea of minimizing corruption
is a completely parallel set of issues
in addition to
increasing diversity and representation
thank you ellen yes i i think it's a
really good question and how to answer
but
um my suspicion is that it will realign
their behavior with the common interests
and the public interest at least to a
degree because what i observed
even in the context of the french
business convention for climate which
which was you know purely advisory
is that they had the parliamentarians
had to
and the government had to kind of like
take into account this input
and had to justify themselves publicly
as to why they ignore certain proposals
and that creates a form of deliberative
accountability
and that is then you know these
arguments are mediatized and people
journalists can press questions i mean
there's it's
it becomes harder for the elected
parliamentarians to stay stuck in
partisan logics and ignore
what the larger public represented by
this mini public
arguably wants so i think it's for the
better
rob so i think
the uh questioner gets is sort of what
the
organizing principle in my presentation
was that we have to change incentives
and i think these two proposals do
give a couple little examples for each
one so the ranked choice ballot
by just giving people backup preferences
just means that you now as a candidate
have this different incentive to talk to
more people
you particularly see this again in
nonpartisan or primary elections
you will see you know regularly the the
winners say gosh
or losers too you know this was really
interesting i mean i just
threw out the playbook that you just
talked to your base and swing voters and
and talk to everybody and just look for
a connection right which is what you
want i think
and that just comes from the voter knows
that they now have a second or third
choice that could matter and so they
need to think
more about candidates and the candidate
knows that and that ultimately as a
representative just has learned a lot
more about the people there
that they're going to represent not the
be all and end all but a clearly just
sort of
uh step forward the multi-member
district particularly you know with
with a proportional system um and these
are these candidate-based american-style
kind of forms of proportional voting
we've had some examples of them but but
when you
the the the two really kind of clears
differences
are that every representative will
will share constituents with someone
from a different party
so you have a different reason when
you're sort of serving your constituency
to talk with people of another party
because you actually
share representative you know you share
constituents and you're
when the parties retreat to their
caucuses they kind of bring the whole
country the whole state in
in into the room and the interests of
cities are part of republican caucuses
and of rural areas are part of
democratic caucuses
and so the attentiveness of both
caucuses
major parties at least to to be thinking
kind of thinking about the whole country
changes
and of course the rank choice feature
kind of creates different
different opportunities to be rewarded
for getting for for sort of solving
problems
for for at least some representatives
that's what they will be in office for
and they can get reelected to do that
so thanks to all the panelists for uh
offering
fresh ideas and insights on a perennial
question how do we get a better
representation and hopefully better
outcomes
a reminder just to visit the isps
website
isps.yale.edu
keep up with events you can also join
our mailing lists
to receive a monthly newsletter um uh
event information on future events
uh or follow us on twitter and facebook
and lastly just a big thank you to the
organizers pam green
uh pamela monica tori bilsky and lamora
peer
of course to all the people in the
audience who have such great questions
and participated so much
so thank you very much and we'll see you
the next event